le fameux botox utilisé en médecine
esthétiques fait son entrée aux
traditionnels entretiens de bichat
un sujet qui concerne de nombreuses
femmes ce produit est utilisé pour
combler les rides mais il n'est pas sans
risques le point avec nathalie sapina et
jean françois oman à gauche le
chirurgien à droite les patientes pour
le premier verrou nick 46 ans adepte du
botox depuis deux ans et voilà le
résultat le franc lui fait parfait
pascal sa copine elle s'apprête à
essayer une contraction de 2 du muscle
ce qui se comprend dans la leur soucieux
le botox c'est le nom commercial de la
toxine botulique un poison que l'on
injecte à dose infinitésimale dans les
muscles du front pour les paralyser
conséquence après quelques jours plus de
rides
un effet qui dure environ six mois
regardez comme je fais ça heureusement
quand un petit peu de gens profitent
selon trois jours ça ne se rate et plus
j'ai l'air agressif voiliers et je
trouve pas ça très joli
le principal risque du botox que le
médecin ait la main un peu lourde
quelquefois le vue peut être un peu plus
important le front peu refait le voit un
divorce jeunes du rhdp l'autre risque
c'est de tomber sur un médecin qui ne
pense qu'à son chiffre d'affaires et ça
arrive il ya 100 unités dans un flacon
ce qui normalement devrait vous
permettent de faire deux passions de
traiter de patients si vous mettez que
dix unités par patient vous avez faire
dix patients avec un flacon ce qui est
d'une malhonnêteté évidente mais chaque
patient aura besoin d'eux
de revenir et de revenir ed revenir
c'est ce que j'appelle vulgairement la
médecine tiroir caisse pascal elle a été
bien traités une semaine après son
médecin constate que résultats pas
besoin de retouches
maintenant j'ai plus l'air crispé comme
ça je peux pas le faire de toute façon
on pas ce qu'on va faire ça donc je le
sens détendue jamais aucune technique de
médecine esthétique n'a connu un tel
succès depuis un an que le botox est
autorisé en france
la demande explose malgré le kun une
séance 500 euros